you're 80 something you're not like man
I'm so glad I'm worth 10 billion instead
of five they're like man I wish my kid
were here Clayton Christensen who was a
Harvard business professor guy like
killed life and he wrote this book
called How you measure your life where
he talks about like a lot of his Harvard
Business School friends they only
measured their life with money because
it was the easiest thing to measure not
because it was the most meaningful you
can work late one night and your
marriage probably won't be different
like if you missed dinner one night but
the problem is that they'll sacrifice
that like today thing but they lose the
long-term benefit and they sacrifice
that for the short-term benefit of the
promotion of the recognition short-term
discount for long-term achievement
people usually don't make that trade